what's up
[Music]
you guys steal
a semi truck worth 280
000 I've always wanted just the truck
yeah the truck itself is like six
figures like that very expensive trailer
just 280 Grand some of them got bunk
beds in the back yeah that's sweet you
could sleep in it and this guy doesn't
even have a generator what do you do
what do you do if it's reported missing
and you want to get away from the cops
and you want to get away from them yeah
you want to keep it away oh because you
stole it gotcha oh I know you hire one
of those sidewalk chalk uh painters
right you know they can make you look
like whoa It's the top of a building but
it's only just like Hollywood Boulevard
but you all have to look at it from one
angle that's highly elaborate you paint
the semi truck into like a brick
building oh that is really goddamn good
brochures Criminal Mind Criminal Mind oh
wait but the cops are gonna go [__] you
painted no not wind chills yeah you're
painted like a bush Okay yeah windchill
still exist oh yeah baby damn I love
windshields they got hot sandwiches now
oh the wind chill is kind of fire bro
you're like no I love winchells that was
my favorite one until the cambodians
came and destroyed it you gotta go at
3am Cambodia Donuts are good though
they're so [__] good they mastered it
rightfully they took it over there's
documentaries about cambodians and
donuts dude yup my friends I would park
it at the runaway truck ramp like right
on the where the dirt's really high
that's really good you can't see over it
yeah and nobody goes and checks those
things they don't does it got a low
Jacks it does not have a low Jack okay
so I'll I'll park it behind some trees
and I'll leave it there until the cops
get busy with other things close a hiker
always finds it though in those
situations really no so the guy are we
already done being creative about it go
for it no that's cool what would you do
I was just wondering how long it would
take to like repaint the whole thing but
I was like damn that'll take me like a
month that is a really stupid idea you
watch too much you play too much GTA
you talk you know it's coming he was
gonna paint it into a Winchell's and a
bush he gave me compliments you came up
with a grand
I was just taking the prompt seriously I
wanted to know what I was going to do
with this truck turned into Optimus
Prime actually unfortunately Anthony was
right that is exactly what happened what
do you do repaint the whole thing dude
he [__] paid and sprayed it
the thing was this thing was pink and he
painted it orange that's too close of a
color pink is the new orange he should
have made it black or something no he he
decided to he's like they won't know if
I if I how good of a job did he do wow
he did a pretty good job that's kind of
smart actually like it looks I mean part
of it's still pink oh they didn't do
that good of a job God damn it why would
you get an orange I mean at the end of
the day you're not gonna be looking for
an orange Chuck but you can see the pink
right but that's the thing if you see
pink you're like wait a minute yeah it's
like there's still remnants of yeah
every day you see a pink Peterbilt
that's true the heck is that what it's
called that's one of the brands I didn't
know that those things were 280 Grand
right
um he decided to paint it
um and he stoled it parked it by a hotel
in the background of a parking lot cool
and then
um people thought that like a guy
out in broad daylight spray painting a
semi truck in the parking lot of a hotel
was kind of a suspicious thing and so
they called the cops on us
dude isn't it funny how like every day
you'll be driving on the roads and
there'll be like a Lambo or something
nice that's like 80 100 000 but these
things are everywhere and they're like
twice three times the amount of money
they don't even know we're not impressed
we're just like you can't fit it in a
garage yeah I mean the idea that like if
you look at things of monetary value I
wish criminals alley-ooped themselves
better like you probably got a homie
that has a paint shop right before you
steal it schedule it with them hey I'm
gonna be breathing in a semi truck
tomorrow clear your schedule because I
need I need that thing painted in like
four hours I don't trust criminals to be
on time and then that way you just bring
it in bam painted you'll come out you
know versus spraying in the back of a
hotel it is we a weird place to spray
paint something like if I was just yeah
I'll go to a gas station and then maybe
people like okay maybe he's working on
his car in some way or go to the truck
wash or like the race station or
something but what do you think is this
guy's intentions he's gonna like paint
it and sell it yeah I feel like this guy
just stole it and was like all right
what's next you know like because maybe
he's gonna steal cargo oh yeah so he
could pull up to the bed he could pull
up to the [__] port and go I'm here
to do some load it up Luke yeah and
you're like wait what what are you pick
picking up one of those containers and
he just drives off with it and then he
just opens it and goes oh I got a lot of
baby carts today dude you know what's
crazy that reminds me of a story that my
uncle told me about in the 80s my uncle
had like a van like mine where it looked
like a crazy like an 18 van like an 18
rocker band and he went to pick up my
mom at the airport and he got in line
with all these other vans that were
waiting because that was like the van to
drive back then and then he didn't
realize that
um this like rock concert was in town
and a bunch of artists were arriving and
those vans that he was in line with were
the Vans to take artists to the venue
and then he got stuck in there and then
they tried to get in yeah I think it's
like white snake or some kind of really
popular band just got in his van and
they were like all right we gotta go we
gotta go and so he was like all right
and didn't pick up my mom and he took
them to the concert that's so funny and
then they liked him so much they hired
him to like transport for the rest of
the concert season and your mom
the opportunity of a lifetime it was
just by chance you're not going to
believe I don't know I think it was
somebody like somebody yeah that's
[__] cool yeah like some popular band
but he was just like uh okay all right
what a cool [__] story yeah then my
mom was just like where is she yeah
she's at the kind of worth it though
yeah like she's probably on the pay
phone too yeah did he leave yet
yo [__] was so difficult back to if you
weren't on [__] time people start
panicking don't be like what the [__] is
this guy's dead it just reminds me of
like if you're just in a place and you
just act like that's where you're meant
to be people don't really know like they
just they just keep going yeah that's
crazy
um so these these when they were caught
by the way they were still in the
process of spray painting and they were
they were carefully taping it off and
like doing a pretty good job actually so
that's why I respect that's why you
still see pink is because they were
they're not done
uh they're like we didn't get to finish
that part they had a GPS
um but it was disabled and chucked it in
the woods so nearby though so they kind
of knew it
still nearby
this guy this guy has to kind of know a
lot about trucks because you those are
not normal to drive like oh you were me
you were moves you got in it we would go
we would know how to drive some of them
have printers in the dash you know that
and it prints out like weather reports
and stuff
I used to read books about weird [__] as
a kid so I knew a lot about semi trucks
dude you're a truck guy you explained
why you knew that with a bunch of
different [__] huh there's still I think
they're like
damn it diesel preemptive dude that's
the funny thing you just did what in the
same breath you Justified why you knew
something like you went yeah they just
had printers I used to read a lot of
weird [__] as a kid that's why I know
that yeah so don't make fun of me that's
what you need to do I also get him I
also got sent the time out a lot you
know like go to the back of the class
and in the back of the class they have
all those books so when you start
reading these [__] books and [__] so
I know about [__] like what's that
blind chick Helen Keller
that blind
yeah I forgot a lot of good jokes no
she's blind and deaf right yeah I was
like that's a hard life yeah that's what
you learned that was every bit about her
and then and then and I learned about
the fat baseball player Yogi Babe Ruth
oh oh yeah I read a lot about these
things this is what I should do yeah
that's your that's how that's the
antidote it encounters him yeah it
counts me you guys it's all [__]
Cloud Anthony too [__] scumbag
I never make fun of Anthony I try to
support him and he turns his back on me
this is why I don't go to YouTube
because you're a [__] when Anthony
fumbles the ball we're everyone Dives on
it not just me
it's your fault dude because you say
something really funny that we all have
to laugh at okay I've never seen Anthony
fumble anymore he [__] dropping them
all over the field dude nice killer
the idea of saying something is
justifying like don't make fun of me all
right I know that because of this I was
a weird kid you know right after right
after college when we were like um going
through like a hard ass like economic
downturn like I couldn't find a job or
anything like that right one of the
things I'm thinking about doing was be a
truck driver dude that's a great
decision actually my dad was a truck
driver because it was like oh really
yeah like for like I thought that's what
they sounded but he drove an audio truck
no after a while he kind of was like he
couldn't get work so then he just
started truck driving how the heck is
like that not be able to get work he did
every legendary film in a row I don't
know you gotta ask him bro holy [__]
maybe he was a jerk bring it to Dad dude
maybe he was a jerk maybe he was
difficult to work
so some people might say I don't know
more great do you think he's sitting
there and some new directors tell him
some [__] and he's like yeah I think
I'll be okay I did Indiana Jones thanks
you know what Loki I wouldn't put it
fast
I wouldn't put a pasta I think my dad's
a [__] rookie ass right at the same
time I bet he was [__] pain in the
ass sometimes he's just like an old
Taiwanese dad and I'm like dude shut up
it's so funny to say that I did Indiana
Jones wouldn't you um I did Raiders okay
yeah this is going to be way harder than
that Spielberg film I did every year for
the past decade
um oh I'm sorry I did Tron thanks though
he's always like he's like
[Music]